sébastien achète un sapin de noël
artificiel
quelques jours après il regrette son
hasharon on préfère avoir un vrai sapin
alors sébastien retourne au magasin pour
se faire rembourser
malchance le commerçant refuse sébastien
est étonné la boîte est encore fermée il
a juste changé d'idée le commerçant at
il le droit de refuser de reprendre le
sapin et oui parce que la loi n'oblige
pas un commerçant avoir une politique de
retour donc le magasin n'est pas tenue
de rembourser ni d'échangé l'article ni
de remettre le note de crédit à
sébastien ogier donc au bon vouloir des
commerçants et c'est la même chose dans
toutes les provinces canadiennes le fin
mot de l'histoire
croire que la loi oblige un commerçant à
vous rembourser parce que vous allez
changer d'idée c'est comme croire au
père noël